well we're at one of uh three cordons in
liverpool tonight in what is a major
incident
led by the northwest counter terrorism
unit it happened just before
the minute silence was held across the
country
and
from what we know
we think it was a taxi pulled up to the
liverpool women's hospital
and then there was
some sort of explosion
the car
was destroyed by fire one man we know
died in that fire another man the dry he
was a passenger the driver got out of
that vehicle
and was injured had to be taken to
hospital the area was obviously
sealed off
and then shortly afterwards this cordon
and another one was set up meanwhile um
a brief news conference was held
by the chief constable
and that told us something about how
seriously this was being taken here is
what she had to say
so far we understand that the car
involved was a taxi which pulled up at
the hospital shortly before the
explosion occurred
work is still ongoing to establish what
has happened and could
take some time before we in a position
to confirm anything
we are keeping an open mind as to what
caused the explosion but given how it
has happened and out of caution
counter-terrorism police are leading the
investigation supported by merseyside
police
and it wasn't long uh after that
explosion before armed police swooped
here at rutland avenue just a mile away
from the hospital and also at bowler
street in kensington
here residents have been told they are
not allowed to leave their homes they've
been told this cordon at least if they
do leave they won't be allowed to come
back and this cordon they've been told
could be in place for some time
and in the kensington area the police
have confirmed three men have been
arrested in connection with this
incident under the terrorism act aged 21
26 and 29
but it is important to point out that
the terror unit says that it is keeping
an open mind still
about what was behind this explosion and
they are working with merseyside police